google eine plattform die täglich von
millionen von menschen genutzt wird die
einfach keine ahnung von irgendwas haben
und das erstmals suchen müssen und damit
herzlich willkommen zu diesem heutigen
video meine damen und herren mein name
ist luca und ich bin habscheid haare und
ich weiß steht mir auch nicht aber
wenige bill bis ich bin luca ist ihr
google ist eine lustige plattform und
google hat auch nicht nur die funktion
dass man sachen dort eingeben kann und
google einem ausspuckt ok auf den und
den webseiten findet man die wörter
sondern google hat auch einige easter
eggs voran weil sie nicht wissen was
easter eggs sind das ist quasi das motto
ostereier übersetzt ins englische und
auf einer webseite heißt das so quasi
versteckte überraschungen und ich zeige
euch ein paar von google
hier können nämlich mal ganz einfach sql
geben und dann sehen wir schon schief
ist übersetzung aber
hier ist alles
schief das war nicht ich sondern das war
google ich glaube hier unten sieht man
es am besten das nächste geschenk das
ich euch vorstelle ist du barrel rohöl
und zwar wenn wir jetzt älter drücken
seht ihr schon wow
google hat sich komplett im kreis
gedreht cool freut mich google kann
allerdings auch html und zwar wenn man
einfach mal ein gibt es blinkt html
sehen wir schon dass google einfach
klingt alles vor html steht ist jetzt am
aufleuchten und ableuchten cool oder
dieses das ist sehr sehr cool würde das
nächste easter egg hat etwas zu tun mit
der revision und zwar geht es dabei
darum im einfachen sinne dass sich quasi
dinge wiederholen das heißt wenn man
jetzt bei google einfach mal rein gibt
steht google in form eines trikots von
wegen ich habe es zwar genauso
geschrieben aber google wollte ist
einfach noch mal wiederholen weil das
die bedeutung des wortes ist das nächste
kiste erkannt wird von bradley park und
zwar war das damals eine militärische
zentrale bei der der code der wehrmacht
entschlüsselt wurde und wenn man jetzt
bei google hat man einige bley park
sehen wir schon nicht rechts in der
anzeige von wikipedia das hier
google tut quasi so als wird irgendein
code gingst und da kommt jetzt bletchley
park raus wir können google auf fragen
wort sounddock make und dann sehen wir
schon bei der google anzeige hier oben
das hat einfach mal auf und legen können
und auf nashorn oder waschbär oder
truthahn oder eine antilope
und noch viel mehr wie ein alligator
a
da jedoch ein humana in panda büffel
juli an wie ein schiff
und wir können auch hier noch auf mehr
traute klicken dann sehen wir noch ganz
ganz viele weitere tiere von dem wir
euch uns den sound anhören können also
ihr könnt ihr einfach mal auf google
gehen und das selbst machen falls sie
nicht wissen wie tiere klingen ich
glaube wenn ich nicht hier wäre würde
ich mich ca so anhören
[Musik]
das nächste easter egg funktioniert
jetzt nicht wirklich auf meinem desktop
hier vorne das wird auch keinen sinn
machen sondern es funktioniert auf
meinem iphone beziehungsweise auch auf
eurem handy oder auf ihrem laptop wird
das ganze denke ich auch funktionieren
und zwar heißt es babbel level wenn man
babbel level also so geschrieben hier
ist mal konzern wenn man babbel level so
bei google eingibt kommt eine
wasserwaage und da können wir unser
handy quasi so als wasserwaage benutzen
und gucken ob ein bild was an der wand
hängt wirklich gerade hängt oder ob es
komplett schief ist allerdings hat nicht
nur google versteckte easter eggs
sondern auch youtube und das hier ist
erst mal der beste youtube-kanal aber
nie darin die zeit davon und wenn das
will
lassen
man kann bei google nämlich
beispielsweise die haarlem sheikh
eingeben dann geht die ganze website
total ab wenn man das jetzt allerdings
macht funktioniert das ganze nicht mehr
es gab auch für die funktion doku mein
zugeben dass ich dieses dogma und dann
wäre die ganze schriften comics gewesen
allerdings hat youtube deswegen die
rausgenommen weil die sind ja auch
uncool
man kann bei google auch einen geben
google in 1998 und dann ist der erste
link der kommt google beton dort kann
man genau sehen wie die google logos
damals aussah 1998 1999 reichweite da
gab es den vereinigten staaten dann
machen wir 1999 weiter uncle sam
blablabla kommt jetzt gehen wir mal ein
paar jahre vor ein dienstag 2000 hat
dieser doodle zum beispiel schon fast
die komplette welt erreicht außer was
ist das island glaube ich ist es island
das ist oder sind das hier nicht um in
der tat dann gibt es außerdem eine
funktion von google dass man google
nicht als normale webseite nutzt sondern
als die hacker website und da sehen wir
hier solche sachen eingeblendet das
heißt wenn ich jetzt hier beispielsweise
mal hacker einfach eingeben und auf
suchen klicken sehen wir schon dass hier
verschiedene coach stehen genauso wie es
allerdings ein hacker interface gibt
gibt es auch einen piraten interface
hier steht der google search oder
eigenfehler lucky und jetzt können wir
irgendwas eingeben zum beispiel pirate
gebe ich jetzt mal hätte mich auch in
bray windschatten videos likes ein
dislike also ein bisschen sonne piraten
sprache das nächste easter egg ist nicht
auf der web site google.com direkt
erhältlich oder vorhanden sage ich mal
sondern auf der website mg tf y also
letzten wie google wert for you das
heißt man kann jetzt hier einfach mal
einen geben kraft da jetzt klickt man
auf den link jetzt hat man den link hier
vorne wenn ich den link jetzt einfach
mal eingeben und enter drücken meine
damen und herren sehen wir schon dass
hier eine maus kommt die maus geht auf
die web site google.com und dort wird
jetzt kontraste eingegeben google search
und dann gelangt man nämlich auf die
seite
genau hier und jetzt sieht man wer
konkreter ist nämlich ein autor wieder
ein buchstabe wegfallen welchen autos
nächste easter egg hat etwas zu tun mit
google maps das heißt wir geben erst mal
maps einklicken jetzt hier oben auf den
maps und können jetzt hier ja einen ort
eingeben
das heißt ich gebe ich jetzt einfach mal
loch ness ein und dann sehen wir schon
dass unten das symbol wo normalerweise
ein medical ist da ist jetzt ein kleiner
dinosaurier hier also dieses loch ness
monster ich weiß nicht ob es ein
dinosaurier ist ich glaube dass links
und seen monster aber jeden fall ist das
dann da auf den ersten blick sieht diese
website ganz normal aus wie google
früher außer also ein bisschen das
anderen logo wenn wir dann allerdings
jetzt was ein geben wollen und einfach
machen so maus auf die suche zu bewegen
krach das ganze in sich zusammen damit
allerdings deutlich genug sondern wir
können auch noch das logo nehmen und ein
bisschen rum schleudern oder mal hier
gegen die wand hauen oder das ding
einfach mal nehmen und das gegenwärtig
könnt ihr mit den ganzen tag spaß haben
ich habe mir noch viele weitere easter
eggs aus dem internet heraus gesucht
habt ihr alle abfotografiert und könntet
ihr euch jetzt noch alle zeigen die sind
allerdings die meisten davon wirklich
irgendwie im kalten later zu machen oder
dafür muss man sich dann google
herunterladen wo man dann so ein flight
simulator flug machen kann oder die
funktionieren auf irgendwelchen
internationalen webseiten von google
deswegen will ich an der stelle das
heutige video als auch beenden meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich habe mir einfach mal
gedacht es gibt so viele google easter
eggs darüber kann ich endlich mal ein
video machen wenn es euch gefallen hat
das gerne mein leib schreibt in die
kommentare
welchen easter egg ihr cool findet
welchen eventuell mal austesten würdet
ich fand zum beispiel den mit dieses
level google wert von judas werde ich
auf jeden fall in zukunft oft mal
anwenden und sonst ist dieses video
national jetzt auch vorbei und ich würde
sagen